one of the things that is so amazing
about this show is how formidable the
actors are and one of the true
highlights of this season is the scene
where you have rhys and marsha gay
harden you're the truth teller was that
true
being in any scene with marcia gay heart
and you have to stay on your toes
because she will pivot and turn on you
and you better be prepared it's so fun
to have her as a scene partner i think
that people change
i think people grow
i know i'm evolving
i wonder if you are i love that bradley
gets to say that i think we have to make
room for people to change and grow
watching these two titans face off and
have this conversation do you have to
cancel alex is that what we're here to
do or is there an opportunity for
forgiveness it's at the root of what a
lot of people are thinking right now but
not very many people are saying you're
not going to mitch kessler's memorial
are you
i am with the anchor i had to come up
with sort of a backstory so why does he
feel the need to go to the service
knowing what this man has done i think
he's probably there for mitch's kids to
say i knew your dad a long time and i
think on a moral level he needs to do
that for himself
my youngest asked me if all dad's
friends would be there
i think these characters have a choice
to make really asking themselves when
our heroes end up being more villainous
than we thought well how am i going to
respond to this and i think true to life
some people decide that i'm going to
respond to the man that i know the man
that was in front of me
um i wasn't going to come but i just
kept feeling that i
had to and to say a few words about
mitch
and what he meant to me
for alex she sacrifices her legacy in a
way by going to the funeral and speaking
the truth i think it's the beginning of
the big shift for her i'm gonna be
canceled
corey for things that i did
alex i think feels pretty much at the
bottom of the barrel as a human being
the loss of her only friend soul mate on
the planet her hypocrisy within herself
what she asked him to do the guilt of
that
it's like that thread in a sweater
that's just getting pulled and it's just
gonna
unravel and unravel and unravel until
she finally just kind of
you'll see
[Music]
you